In this video we shall review how to handle false positives in BurpSuite Enterprise Edition.
You may want to do this if manual testing shows that an issue is not really present,
or if you are aware of the issue but do not want to rectify it. To mark an issue as a false positive,
first from the top menu select scans. Then select the scan that you wish to view. Next,
click the issues tab and locate the vulnerability in question. Now you can select mark as false positive.
In the pop-up window select a reason. You can select this issue to mark only this instance of
the issue as a false positive. You can select this issue and all existing issues with the same type
for the site. This marks all issues of the same type as false positives across the whole site.
Or we can select this issue and all existing issues with the same type and URL for the site. This marks
issues of the same type and URL as false positives. Finally, we can select all issues of this type in
the current scan only. This marks all issues of this type as false positives but only for the current scan.
Finally, select OK. In the issues window, the selected issues are now moved to the bottom of the list,
labelled as false positive. They are also greyed out. They will be removed from stats and charts displayed
in the dashboard. Please note marking an issue as false positive does not affect future scans. To configure
future scans to mark certain issues by default, refer to configuring default false positive settings
documentation. Thank you.